sometimes we'd scroll through raya why
would you post your sandwich last time i
talked to you guys i got to play with
puppies that's a talent
a guy had a cabinet a gut-headed
godmother
you jerk hi i'm hilary duff and i play
sophie on how i met your father hi i'm
francia raisa and i play valentina on
how i met your father today we are here
with buzzfeed to take the co-star test
bronco we got this okay oh yeah she
calls me frog i haven't heard that in so
long
okay the first question is if i know
francia's birthday and i do because i
googled it i'm just gonna confess right
now
that um i didn't know her birthday but
that's a tough question who knows
birthdays it's july 26th and i was very
upset because i forgot that you're a
you're younger than me
1988.
she's not 34 yet
coming pretty soon so i also googled and
i didn't know we had this but hillary
gave it away and it is september 28
1987. she's a year older than me one
extra wrinkle the next question is the
first time we met and i remember the
first time we met i was heavily pregnant
with um
my son luca and it was in my mom's
kitchen francie asked me if i had lost
my mucus plug yet
yep yeah that happened uh the first time
we met i was hanging out with uh haley
her sister and you know grew up watching
her i was nervous and i was trying to
play cool and i had just learned what a
mucus plug was because my friend was
pregnant and i was like i'm gonna share
that i'm smart have you lost your mucus
plug not realizing how um personal that
is
but you were amazing about it because
you laughed at me and you were like
thanks for asking no
no one want to talk about a mucus slug
but when it's happening to you you're
like i'm dying to lose it but it hasn't
happened yet yeah what were you like 24.
i was 23.
yeah i made a good first impression guys
but memorable favorite snack at crafty
this is really tough i'm not gonna say
that i know her favorite snack at crafty
but i do know that the girl can take
down a bag like this big
of um chile pistachios you're absolutely
right i'd say that's the top snack in
your life that was the top snack in my
life when i discovered them but on set i
always had turkey sandwiches and chips
yeah by the way i think you got on that
turkey sandwich train because i told you
that they'll make them for you
and you were like where'd you get that
one yeah that was all you she showed me
the ropes i don't know if you have a
go-to would you get smoothies yeah i'd
get like a shake yeah yeah you get like
a shaker smooth stuff yeah but also she
loves the sneaky bag of chips oh yes
because every time i had my chips you'd
be like give me some and go get it we
like the same flavors except for
sometimes i have a sweet tooth and she
doesn't but like it would be like a like
10 30 and she'd be like getting down on
a bag of jalapeno chips and i'm like
girl you're taking me down with you oh
your favorite snack on set is my salsa
that's what it is that's true but you
didn't hook that up until like the last
two weeks well i didn't know i didn't
know it would be such a hit your
dressing room must have well you have
your little um
like sash
massage there was a lot of candles in
there smelly good smelly stuff i'm gonna
say you can't mark that right because my
my dressing room must have is yarn damn
it i knew that
[Applause]
i'm gonna say that your dressing room
must have is music dang you got that
right go to activity between filming
scenes face timing with her kids or
watching videos of her kids oh that's so
embarrassing but probably true sometimes
we'd scroll through raya
while we were
filming it was a five minute moment a
five minute moment that's it
i mean i deleted it before we wrapped
that's true on this that yeah i was on
riot a lot between takes you're right i
remember being excited about that
because i don't get to i'm not obviously
not on a dating app i don't get to no i
don't i'm glad i'm not but like it was
very fun learning raya she's like no no
no not good enough i'd be like what
about him no
give me that i wanna or i'd be like oh i
know him
oh my favorite was i don't like the
sandwich he's eating no why would you
post your sandwich their giveaway that
they're about to break character frank
breaks character more than me i think
yeah you're pretty good about it
sometimes things are so funny that you
would laugh but i think more than that
it would be like an inside joke and then
we would like break a little bit right
yeah yeah i think if we looked at each
other too long or something like that
like i feel like we'd kind of get the
giggles yeah i look down a lot but you
just keep staring at me and you start
yup that's what you do
i think it took us all a second to get
to know what each other meant without
you know how you get to know people
without them having to say anything but
half the time this much of our face was
covered up with like a mask so everyone
would be like like i remembered tom told
me this i'm scared of hillary like i
don't know what she's thinking she
always looks like she's smiling but like
that's not normal they were afraid of
you the whole like first half of the
season they're like i don't know if
she's like
that's so insane
because i'm the least scary person ever
i don't understand if they say something
that like you just don't understand
you'll look at them and be like i don't
get it
and they're like
okay i'm gonna go over here now the
favorite scene that you shot on set okay
i think that your favorite scene is the
one where we're sitting on the curb
outside the club outside of fomo oh that
was a good one i do love that scene i do
love that one i was thinking of um
our ex jane fonda bit is that your
favorite that was funny to me the
bar mitzvah
hell no i don't know the very last scene
oh
damn it the very last scene okay i
didn't get that right oh bud one i don't
know this your favorite character
they've ever portrayed in a different
project oh god let me think uh lizzie
mcguire
come on
i mean listen i'm very quick to tell her
i even asked for a palette i've asked
for many things oh my god the lucy
palette that never was for you um i have
no idea this for you ah you jerk i know
grown-ish and i i want to say i have to
say this one how i met it says in a
different project oh wow okay um i would
say then um probably
probably life-sized too working with
tyra because tyra banks is cool uh their
hometown you're a cali girl
yeah and you're a texas girl that's
right okay uh middle name
oh my god wait francia is your middle
name isn't it no no no
no it's long i don't remember it's on my
uh box right now oh my god that's right
damn it
her her last name is her middle name
god i'm never gonna forget it
place is my middle name i have no idea
what yours is and apparently you're
about to reveal it to the world let's go
i know oh my god it's erhard who i know
there you go it's
e-r-h-r-d and it's like a family passed
on name from texas it's fine now that
i'm older like i'm proud to have the
name but when i was younger my dad said
he found like i would like practice my
autograph when i was like really little
and i would make my middle name emily
because it started with an e
he found like sheets of paper in my desk
drawer from texas that was like hillary
emily duff hillary elizabeth duff
anything but what my middle name was i'm
calling you earhard from now on great
can't wait their go-to order at a bar
yours
mine's a margarita well tequila soda
water uh lime there you go yeah she
basically makes her own version of a
skinny margarita with all these
ingredients and yeah lime juice you'll
first order a whiskey drink of some sort
and then decide that you don't like it
and then order some sort of red wine
bingo
and their secret talent i don't think
it's a secret but you're like a badass
dancer oh thank you
and salsa maker yeah well the salsa you
you made that known you made that known
so yeah you crochet that was a new
hidden talent that we learned about she
made a lot of cute little hats for some
of our crew and i can speak gibberish
yes she showed off that talent and i
already have a hard time speaking
english so it doesn't help that she does
this
two different kinds one's called ob and
that's like what my husband speaks so
i've learned that but it's really much
more challenging but like growing up
with my sister i'd speak gibberish and
i'd be like other guy had a governor
and i just said i have not had my coffee
today i just thought of a secret talent
so in episode two we talk about the
thing that charlie does with the tongue
i can do it lucky charming
oh
he does this thing what is he telling
where he oh yeah you can i can't do that
i don't i learned it in middle school so
i was laughing hard when that came about
that's a talent
i only got 60
it says i got 10 out of 14 right you
know absolutely everything there is to
know about your co-star you got to know
each other extremely well while you were
filming together and it shows this
better not be the last time we see you
together in front of the screen how i
met your father premieres on january
18th on hulu and here it goes in
gibberish at a guy again pedigree
let's hang out let's be okay
[Music]